elle sa vie on va partir au revoir le
cabinet en voir l'écran voir les ans
bernard vallat famille on parle on va
aller au portugais rui cao papa maman
vous n'êtes pas vieux ah oui assène
reste juste jeunes depuis plus longtemps
que les rats da silva te prendre pour
une auxiliaire d'éducation si tu dis oui
une fois c'est mercredi tous les jours
combien de tours de manège ah bah c'est
pas du tout
cette chanson one
enfin
en fait pas ça tous les mercredis tu vas
y c'est à forlan et toi pareil si tu
réponds pas depuis ce matin j'ai essayé
de vous appeler il faut quelque chose à
fort qu'on va la télé tu as dû te
laisser manger réunion il faut pas qu'on
m'en parle mais ton père ils arrivent
peut regarder le corps de la continence
le souhaite à personne je raccroche vite
tempère me demande la bassine change pas
les plans par s'installer au portugal
moi je suis plus trop serein avec
maintenant qu'il va partir moi j'ai
connu des gens mourant je mettais de 10
ans à mourir pour ma mère
je suis très inquiet ouais je vois
que vous examinez
enfin je suis pas sa mère
la retraite
et c'est l'un des membres les plus beaux
de la vie ne pas rater ça
mon fils a pris sa retraite et si
mokhtar bim crise cardiaque pour 20 ans
il avait 61 ans vous avez quel âge ou 70
vous avez déjà bien profiter quand même